[Music]
feels like Prince Harry and Megan Markel
are engaged
this comes after months of anticipation
the Royal and actress were first linked
in October 2016 and things seems to get
serious fast
that November the palace confirmed the
romance with a rare statement saying
certain media have been too invasive to
Megan and her family since then the two
have stayed largely private about their
romance though they have accompanied
each other to key events Megan was
Harry's date for a friend's wedding in
March 2017
they spent Easter together in April and
in September these photos the two
holding hands cuddling laughing at an
event for the Invictus games which were
created by Harry and then the suit's
star graced the cover of the October
issue of Vanity Fair with this headline
quote wild about Harry I might want to
go very inside she opened up about their
romance being thrust into the spotlight
quote right out of the gate it was
surprising the way things changed but I
still have this support system all
around me and of course my boyfriend
support we are two people who are really
happy and love